l annonce avait déjà été faite il ya
quelques semaines par la présidente du
conseil régional d'île de france valérie
pécresse la région ne reprendra pas
l'opievoy à sa charge en effet le
bailleur social victime aujourd'hui de
la loi allure n'existera plus soul à sa
forme actuelle et sera donc dissout
certains départements comme le val
d'oise vont donc leur attacher leur
logement alors office hlm départemental
dont les yvelines en existe pas pierre
bédier le président de l'opl voix s'est
entrenu s'est entretenu pardon avec les
dirigeants de la structure la semaine
dernière on les coûts tout de suite il
était au micro de williams elle donc
l'opievoy va se scinder en une partie
qui ira vers l'office départemental du
val d'oise c'est la partie qui déjà n'en
parle d'oise du patrimoine en val d'oise
le patrimoine de l'essonne et des
yvelines sera regroupé dans une entité
qui ne peut pas être nos fils public
puisque c'est la loi elle interdit
l'inter départementale it est donc ce
sera une société anonyme je précise que
les règles de gestion de la société
anonyme hlm et des règles de gestion de
l'office public hlm sont très proches
donc le plus important c'est qu'il n'y
aura ni licenciement ni hausses de loyer